Smarter than a beaver and as heroic as Schwarzenegger,
Naru from "Prey" has plenty of amazing moments
— but which ones are the best and bravest?
Right away in the first five minutes of "Prey,"
we're given a telling glimpse into the kind
of character Naru will prove herself to be.
At the start of the movie, Naru's trusty dog
Sarrii gets her tail stuck in a bear trap.
Not only does this foreshadow later scenes
in which bear traps will appear in much more
dire circumstances, it also says a lot about
Naru without any dialogue at all.
By saving her dog, the first thing we get
to know about Naru is her compassion and her
utter fearlessness when a loved one is hurt.
Despite her struggles with them, she values
her family and will protect them at all costs.
However, this isn't all there is to the movie's
young Comanche hero.
She is, above all, incredibly driven to prove
herself as a hunter, despite the gender norms of her tribe.
This drive will go on to inspire her actions
throughout "Prey."
"Why do you want to hunt?"
"Because you all think that I can't."
Director Dan Trachtenberg and his crew clearly
recognized their obligation to bring some
sweet new gadgets for the Predator to use,
and "Prey" delivers spectacularly on this front.
However, one of the coolest pieces of tech
in the film is actually developed by Naru.
Early on into hunting the alien, she ties
a rope to her hatchet in order to be able
to throw and retrieve the weapon quickly.
Trachtenberg revealed during an interview
with ComicBook.com that he drew inspiration
from the 2018 "God of War" video game for
this rope ax that allows Naru to pull off
some stylish kills without ever losing her
trusty weapon.
It goes on to pay off with a crucial role
in the movie, particularly in the scene when
Naru first stumbles into the quicksand swamp
and finds herself sinking with seemingly little
hope of escape.
The only way out is to use the rope ax to
latch onto a downed tree and pull herself up.
This moment highlights Naru's resourcefulness
and her ability to think on her feet — a
unique form of bravery that will prove to
be important later on.
After attacking the Comanche hunting party
in the bloody scene prior, the Predator stalks
Naru and Itsee into the tall grass clearing
near the camp.
Hiding out in the grass, Itsee, an overconfident
hunter in the Comanche tribe, spots the Predator
and prepares his bow, thinking that he and
Naru have the upper hand.
"We have him."
"No, he has us."
Naru saves Itsee from being shot, but as the
two run away, Itsee is caught by the Predator
and dies in one of the most brutal deaths
"Prey" has to offer.
This moment illustrates that although she
hasn't gotten the chance to prove herself,
Naru truly is a skilled hunter who uses her
instincts to assess any kind of situation.
She has the wisdom to recognize that choosing
what keeps you alive in a long battle of attrition
with a foe like the Predator is always the
correct choice.
After the Predator's assault on the French
trappers' camp, Naru returns to retrieve Sarii,
but she's surprised to find that one of the
men still clings to life.
The survivor turns out to be the group's translator,
Raphael.
He begs Naru to heal him before he bleeds
out.
However, taking advantage of her position
of power, she will only do it if Raphael teaches
her how to use his Flintlock pistol.
Barely clinging to life, the translator has
no choice but to agree to her terms.
After demonstrating how it works, he gives
her the Flintlock and Naru gives him medicinal
herbs to treat his bleeding wound.
After she uses the herbs on Raphael, the Predator
returns, allowing Naru to discover a hidden
property of her medicine.
The Predator can't see Raphael due to the
medicine reducing his body heat, and that's
when Naru realizes that its vision is based
on heat signatures.
This moment is, of course, a big reference
to the original "Predator," echoing the scene
in which Arnold Schwarzenegger's Dutch discovers
that the Predator can't see him when he's
covered in mud.
As sharp as she may be, Naru really rides
the line between being brave and being an
idiot when she decides to leave the camp without
telling anyone where she's headed.
In pursuit of the Predator, Naru is getting
in way over her head.
Ultimately though, this proves to be an act
of bravery instead of foolishness, and ending
up as a real turning point in "Prey."
Naru needs to embark on her "kühtaamia,"
a rite of passage that all hunters must undergo
in order to prove themselves to the tribe.
The details of this ritual are important,
since they require the hunter to hunt an animal
that can also hunt them — a predator.
Naru realizes before everyone else that the
alien interloper is a hunter, and she accepts
his arrival as a sign it is her time to be
tested.
The moment she decides to go out on her own,
without anyone's help, Naru commits to making
this hunt her kühtaamia, and that drive to
prove herself to everyone inspires her for
the rest of the movie.
At the end of the movie, Naru gets to complete
her arc in a triumphant finale.
As she returns from the hunt victorious, she
comes back to the camp covered in neon green
Predator blood with the head of her prey held
in her hands.
It's the most empowering moment Naru gets
in the whole movie, bringing her character full circle.
As the community gathers around her, she tosses
the head at the feet of the tribe's leader
to accept her rightful place as a Comanche
warrior.
This isn't merely Naru coming back from her
kühtaamia, regularly a cause for celebration,
but her returning as the savior of her tribe.
Having killed the creature that took her brother
and most of the male hunters, Naru has made
her way to the top of the food chain in a
short matter of time.
With most of the hunters dead, Naru remains
the singular defense the tribe has.
After they're both independently captured
by the French trappers, Naru and Taabe are
tied up to a tree together and used as bait
for the Predator.
But since the Predator only hunts humans and
animals who pose a threat to it, it ignores
the captives and goes straight for the armed
trappers who are waiting in the wings to attack.
Amid the chaos, Naru thinks on her feet to
figure out how to free herself and Taabe from their ropes.
Upon seeing the bear trap on the group near
their restraints, Naru figures out how she
can use it to cut their ropes.
Trachtenberg uses this opportunity to trick
the viewer, as Naru begins telling Taabe a
story about how a beaver will escape from
traps by chewing its own leg off.
Taabe begins to panic, thinking his sister
is about to sacrifice her limb for their freedom.
But as we've learned, Naru always thinks past
the obvious answer to find a better one.
"Naru stop!"
"...I'm smarter than a beaver."
One of the most brutal moments in "Prey" doesn't
even need a Predator around to set off a flurry of violence.
Instead, in a moment showing the parallels
between our young hero and the movie's young
Predator, Naru is the instigator of this assault.
When sneaking up on the trapper camp, she
sees that they have captured Sarii and intend to harm him.
When she springs into action, Naru is quick
and deadly.
Using her assailants' weapons against them,
as well as her own rope ax, she swiftly puts
an end to the remaining trappers.
It's the moment that shows the most violent
side of her, but it is crucial to proving
that she's ready to take on the Predator.
Only now that as she matches the efficiency,
bravery, and brutality of her prey can she
understand how to take it down.
According to The Escapist, one of the elements
of the original "Predator" that Dan Trachtenberg
picked up and amplified in "Prey" is its commentary
on colonialism.
The anti-colonial themes are summed up in
the antagonistic relationship between the
Comanche and the French trappers.
The movie becomes as much about Naru facing
off against them as it does about her hunt for the Predator.
In the end, the final trapper's fate is the
most brutal of them all — but the elaborate
plan that Naru uses to kill two birds with
one stone shines as one of her bravest moments.
"You can't see, but I'm killing you."
After we see Naru sneaking up on the trapper,
we see that she has tied him up in an elaborate
setup to lure the Predator out.
She's cut off his leg below the knee, bleeding
him in order to attract the alien while hiding
herself to its gaze using the medicinal herbs.
Needless to say, it's incredibly dangerous
to attract a Predator to you, but this is
the type of bravery Naru needs as a hunter
to complete her rite of passage.
At the end of "Prey," Naru gets to put her
bravery to the test in one final face-off
with the Predator.
After luring her prey into the Frenchman-baited
trap, Naru begins to use her wits and tools
to prove herself as the true predator.
The first and most important part of the plan
is to shoot the Predator point blank in the head.
Not only does this strategy inflict a major
head wound to her foe, but it ends up being
crucial to how the fight plays out.
When Naru shoots the Predator with the Flintlock,
his mask flies off.
Earlier, Naru had observed that this mask
controls the targeting on the Predator's spear gun.
She knows he is weaker without it, so she
cleverly uses the element of surprise to seriously
handicap her enemy.
As you watch "Prey," it becomes clear that
many moments of Naru's final fight have been
plotted out in advance, but one of the best
scenes in the sequence comes when she's forced to improvise.
Near the swamp trap, Naru is forced between
two rocks by the Predator, with its shield
coming down slowly, threatening to decapitate
her.
With the Predator bearing down on her, Naru
grabs a hold of the mandible horn coming out
from its mouth area.
She uses it to stab the Predator in the face,
and takes advantage of the moment when the
beast cries out in pain to flee.
It's a small beat in the middle of this awesome
fight, but it stands out due to its sheer brutality.
The elaborate and ingenious trap that Naru
sets up to finally take down the Predator
is definitely the coolest moment in "Prey."
The film keeps you on your toes throughout
the entire climatic battle, only to reveal
at the moment of the final kill that Naru
has had everything in the bag the whole time.
From the start of the sequence when she's
hunting the trapper, Naru has been setting
her plan into motion.
Immediately after she took the shot, she grabbed
the mask so she could later put it in its
strategic place in the tree near the swamp.
When she finally lures the Predator into the
swamp, she has the mask's targeting lasers
aimed right at it.
When it attempts to fire its spears at Naru,
the projectiles miss and hone in on the Predator
instead, killing it immediately.
In her victorious moment, Naru reminds us
that killing the Predator was never about
firepower – it was about embracing the traits
of a good hunter.
Patience, cunning, and bravery all help Naru
defeat the Predator with its own equipment.